l'Ukraine est cette question la
contre-offensive a-t-elle débuté
officiellement non mais tout le laisse
croire selon plusieurs sources des
opérations ukrainiennes sont en cours
dans la région de zapporijah dans le
dombasleymer Zelensky a annoncé obtenir
des résultats bien joué à darkmouth
étape par étape a-t-il déclaré les
précisions de notre correspondant du
divers crack
vous savez lundi dernier le 5 juin
l'armée ukrainienne a publié une vidéo
où il y avait écrit sur l'écran il n'y
aura pas d'annonce officielle pour moi
c'était l'annonce officielle en fait
mais ils avaient fait de cette manière
pour souligner l'importance de la
silence l'importance de ne pas
communiquer sur les résultats
préliminaires de la contre-offensive de
ne pas dévoiler les plans et ça c'est
vraiment le mot d'ordre chez les
Ukrainiens ce qui fait que pour avoir
des informations sur ce qui se passe
avec cette contre-offensive on doit
dépendre en grande mesure des chaînes de
télégramme publiées par les Russes des
Russes qui sont plutôt pro Poutine
pro-guerre mais aussi qui veulent dire
en détail ce qui se passe réellement sur
le terrain cela existe et puis des
images satellitaires et si on regarde
ces images satellitaires les analystes
disent que les Ukrainiens ont
effectivement eu quelques avancées sur
trois axes essentiellement sur la ligne
de front c'est à côté de bakkmouth comme
le Président il faisait référence hier
dans son allocution c'est aussi dans le
sud-ouest de la région de Donetsk en
dessous de la ville de velica nouveau
Silka et puis c'est dans la région des
aporisia en direction de oriki là il
semblerait que les ukrainiens et avancés
et pris certaines positions russes pour
ensuite les repères encore ça c'est
l'analyse de quelques analyses qui est
fait en regardant différentes sources
ceux qui semblent claires c'est que les
Ukrainiens ont engagé pour la première
fois des chars léopards c'est cher de
fabrication allemande dans cette
bataille ça c'est une indication de plus
que maintenant c'est une contre-offensif
un peu plus sérieuse il commence à
utiliser l'équipement fourni par l'Ouest
justement pour mener cette
contre-offensive certains il n'y a pas
il a été d'image qui sont publiées par
les Russes qui disent avoir détruit un
certain nombre de ces chars léopard les
photos ne permettent pas de confirmer la
destruction de Charles léopard mais
montre clairement la destruction de
certains
véhicules armés
Ukrainiens en tout cas ils ont
visiblement avancé un peu puis subi un
certain revers mais tout le monde
souligne que il est très important aussi
de ne pas tirer de conclusions à ce
stade pour dire est-ce que c'est en
train de bien se passer pour les
Ukrainiens ou mal